welcome to this video I'm our anguish
yeah I've played him just a couple of
games ago try something different now
the reversed reversed Grand Prix 95 no
not doing that hmm isleta good setup and
don't interesting yeah I mean I just
play that in blitz sometimes those this
reverse Grand Prix it tends to lead to
ya too complicated positions that I
don't understand so it's it's fun to
play sometimes hmm maybe takes I mean he
has to take with a pawn I guess and then
make sure that the night is not coming
to have for I'd might come to f2 to g3
mm-hmm
that doesn't look good let's see what we
can do here sub teacher we should be six
Bishop of seven at least get this out
and yeah just night okay no so why don't
I'm not able to play any f4 f4 business
things 93 95 mm yeah that's not very
convenient
how do I cover this not so easy
doesn't want to play 93 for some reason
I think you really should have done that
I have all kinds of VI em this is not so
clear I can even go 94-year 94 f txf
tags it's probably going to work
Teague's takes on f 59 f 2 king of two
very weird stuff
94 GF night f2 king of two not sure it's
probably not objectively working anyway
I should have played that quicker now we
had time to adjust to that and GF I I
don't really have a great reply to that
that was a bit of a gambling move and FB
for every four should be okay I mean
more than okay but this is the this is
the deal and now King takes and they
don't have a good move them look f8 he
takes it I don't really have a great
compensation I look f3 actually King
takes Queen age three that could be okay
let's try that that is probably going to
be some kind of draw check if not more
if not more takes Queen edge recheck am
I'm Emma winning here actually it's as
possible
I taking the look just lose us Queen h3
Andrew gave aid and so on I think that
just loses so he has to go to g1 Queen
g4 check King edge one look f2 seems to
win seems to win somehow
so well it's just for just one moment
there but i think the check Jack should
be right and now this maybe we should
have one decimal no all right let's play
it let's play that first some here Queen
h4 no not working Queen f3 teenage foyer
maybe it is working what is this move
then aged three I guess then look F aid
forgot about that one time morning I
really forgot about this bloody move
shoot
hmm I really don't want to lose this
game that I really don't Butchie to just
about working
it's not really playing this well but
maybe it doesn't matter I still don't
see you in quincy to even look look h3
even that is not a win
can take the two maybe I don't see you
in here I'm just too bad and there is a
win pretty sure
Quincy 7 you can tick tick all my pieces
no check Jackie so at least I'm getting
a drawer here I'm happy with no time and
so on check check check check check whoa
check run after all Wow come on how
could have won that I don't believe this
Queen B 5 this and there's no win I'm
now there's no winner ha there is really
no when that looks crazy there was a
really funny game so okay um he can play
King f3 and it's is not winning for
black and this I didn't think Jay that I
didn't see like that why is this not
winning Jan we're not winning with this
move Bishop f4 okay look f-14 you three
wins for white so is that dodging
dodging all those bullets cool so this
chatting now what is this actually rook
f8 look f8 looks like the right move I
did that okay so look f8 that is at
least threatening a draw now
and I've tried to understand this
somehow this is what the engine gifts
and gifts now gives Queen h4 or this and
this is a draw it seems some kind of
weird perpetual or what okay not really
clear why this is 0 0 0 maybe some weird
perpetual on my king awesome okay this
is what I am late and now i can take for
the draw i have it i want i thought i'd
would win here but doesn't seem to be
the case simply rook f1 queen g-form
it's also interesting Queen g4 takes
takes rook here and Queenie to going to
be one takes takes and now it's counter
at checkers Czech going to hit Jay can I
go here no Queen you aid so I have to go
back check check check I don't can white
win yeah i don't i don't know i mean
this is a drawing maybe it's at raw okay
i played this move my idea was that now
i have g3 but this is not even this
should work yeah
okay he went there and this is not
winning for black amazing I really
thought I'd with with those rooks there
should be some kind of tactic when
there's no tactic I mean don't forget a
lot materia down yeah he has given back
a piece there but why'd his winning he's
threatening to take all those okay this
happened and now it's a drone yeah I was
thinking that this should win and engine
agrees even though it is so it is fairly
complicated 97 kingi to and now the
problem is that check in this position I
don't have this check as the queen is
covering this Wow very chaotic game but
probably [ __ ] to watch okay thanks for
watching